Well,
he's young people have been drawn up in
the culture of a enormous wealth and
enormous power,
enormous opportunity,
uh,
the least well off of them is
considerably better than the best of
their ancestors.
I think they recognize that they see the
signs of success as a world defined
success and opulence on every hand.
They are surrounded by sensation.
They're surrounded by violence.
They are surrounded by a politics.
None of these are capable of delivering
the goods.
And I think they recognize that and I
think there is a desire to find
something that will last,
something that will do something that
will not disappoint and letting you do
that in very evidently you attempted to
turn back to the elders,
to the wisdom of another age,
uh,
to something that might not seem to have
appeal to you in your earlier phase.
But your earlier phase you recognize was
a deceitful and deceptive one.
You ask Harvard graduates whether all
going and they're all going to go.
Ninety percent of the seniors in any
given class,
say they're going into three cities,
they're going to go to Washington just
to put things right power.
They're going to go to New York to make
lots of money.
Uh,
the material world and the going to Los
Angeles to have fun fantasy.
And I think they've come back from all
three of those cities discovering that
like ours,
there's no there,
there a Washington is not going to turn
the world right side up.
Uh,
all the money in New York doesn't spare
it.
The troubles and tribulations of living
in New York and all the fantasy from
Lala Latin doesn't dull the pain of
living in a life with no meaning and no
value.
And that's a modest symbol.
I think people say,
okay,
that must be another way.
Maybe Jerusalem is the place,
uh,
maybe a,
a,
a pilgrimage to the holy city is the
place.
Maybe some Ashram somewhere,
maybe sitting under a Bodhi tree who
knows?
But there are wiser people than we who
years ago have discovered some of these
truths.
Maybe we even heard them in our youth.
And maybe the trick is to try to
recapture,
recover some of that for ourselves.
Now.
I think that's part of the excitement.
Well,
it's against me that young people are
smiling.
We think that the,
they're not prepared to buy a pig in the
poke,
that they are not prepared to put up
with the,
uh,
the triumph of the material or
limitations that even the most indulgent
to facebook,
a patron,
a under 21 is seeking something that's
of value,
something of worth,
something that will last something that
is permanent and even transforming.
And I think that has to do,
for example,
with the fascination with,
with,
uh,
a science fiction with a myth and
fantasy.
It's the Harry Potter thing.
It's looking for something that is
ultimately true and good.
They are not willing to buy a,
the rather grim,
a valueless,
godless,
spiritualists,
a universe which some of the elders are
quite prepared to sell them.
And I think that that suggests a,
a great hunger desire,
great spiritual movement,
uh,
among the cleverest and most able of
young people they know better than to be
content with less than a less than the
best.
And that's what they're seeking.